la consommation de viande a baissé de
12% en france en dix ans j'ai vraiment
très envie de manger du jambon
je pense que vais je mangerai si jaro
dit oui et depuis quinze jours où quand
on n'a pas eu envie
pourtant à partir des années 70 les
français consomment de plus en plus de
viande en 1970 chaque français a mangé
en moyenne 75 8 kg par an dix ans plus
tard la barbaque a encore pris plus de
place sur les tables avec 88 4 kg
consommés par an et par habitant entre
les français et la viande
c'est donc une véritable histoire
d'amour est ce que vous connaissez les
longs des morceaux lesquels demandé dans
les années 80 et 90 la restauration
rapide est la baisse des prix de la
viande pour notamment exploser la
consommation
résultat les français sont toujours plus
friands de viande
rendez vous compte en 1998 c'est un pic
record de consommation avec 93 2 6 kg
par an et par personne
alors que la france est en plein
scandale de la vache folle les français
continuent d'être attachés à leurs côtes
de bettes malgré une hausse continuelle
de la consommation depuis les années 70
un virage s'opère au début des années
2000 les français délaissent petit à
petit la viande
la consommation baisse 85 kg de viande
consommée par habitant en 2017
les habitudes alimentaires changent la
viande est remplacée par x par des
légumes comme dans cette école en 2011
ces petits parisiens eux ne sont pas
végétariens mais tous les mardis dans
les cantines du 2e arrondissement
c'est jour sans viande les enfants ont
appris que c'est bon pour la planète
pour les animaux est aussi pour eux
si aujourd'hui la viande est moins prisé
qu'auparavant elle n'en est pas pour
autant délaissé selon une étude kantar
en 2018
34% des personnes entendait limiter leur
consommation de viande sans être
végétarien cette pratique alimentaire a
un nom le flexitarisme
[Musique]